hello and welcome
uh to a fifth annual drug discovery and
development virtual conference my name
is james mckim
i am a biochemical and molecular
toxicologist uh by training and i've
been working in the area of in vitro
toxicology for about 25 years
in the last 20 years we've been focused
on the development and validation of new
methodologies
and those methodologies have been
supporting the the replacement of
animals that's our that's our our brass
ring if you will
for the future and we've been working in
academia uh chemical industry and
pharmaceuticals
and i'm looking forward to um talking
you today
about the the work and the progress that
we've made on in vitro platforms that
allow um integrating organs through
simulated blood systems
and so i'm going to be talking to you um
about that platform that was developed
here at iontox
for understanding pharmacokinetic and
toxicological effects of drugs and
chemicals
so why do we need an integrated
organ platform in vitro well it's it's
very important that we over the years
we've seen great improvements in both
tissues and and the analytical
technologies for in vitro work
for the testing of drugs and chemical
safety but now we need to understand
relevant routes of exposure and what
happens after the exposure organ and we
get to the delivery organs the systemic
exposure how do we model that in vitro
we want to be able to study the effects
of multiple organs on the test
chemical we want to be able to look at
the movement across multiple biological
barriers
and we want to be able to develop
pharmacokinetic data and estimate key
parameters for example the auc or
half-life
and
we want to be able to understand
repeated dosing so we want to we want a
repeat dosing dynamic model and then
most importantly we want to be able to
have
the ability to extrapolate this in vitro
data to
in vivo
reality
so multi-organ methods provide important
data that you can't get from a single
cell system
we cannot we can start to ask questions
there's absorption distribution
metabolism
etc
and to do that we need to be able to
study key interactions
the three primary routes of exposure the
the oral uh dermal and lung or
respiratory and therefore we want to
look at interactions like the intestine
to the liver skin deliver lung deliver
and there's a lot of science and
business advantages to these types of
systems we should be able to reduce time
of new drugs and chemicals to market
we should be able to start predicting
without using animals what's happened
happening in humans this would
greatly reduce developmental costs
and it would
rapidly move us towards really a
completely different paradigm in the
evaluation of drugs and chemical safety
so i'm going to be talking to you about
a human dynamic multi-organ platform we
refer to it as hudema
and why heat them up why do we need this
and why is this model different well for
several years now we've been we've all
been reading about organ on a chip
and although this technology is really
quite brilliant in terms of its
engineering there are some disadvantages
um in terms of the biology which i'll go
over
and remember all in vitro systems all
platforms nothing is 100 so there's
advantages and disadvantages to all
platforms
but one of the problems is that when you
miniaturize a platform you can reduce
tissue mass to a level where you just
don't have enough to do a lot of the
biochemical and molecular analyses that
you need to do
fluid volumes get very low
and as a result it's very hard to do
repeated dosing without extremely
sensitive analytical equipment so if you
want to do for example a plasma
concentration type time curve you want
to look at drug
how drug changes over time
you're going to want to take a lot of
samples and that can be difficult
only certain cells can be used
in these models and most of the time
they've been tumor cell lines and
frankly we've really gotten away from
tumor cell lines in the last several
years and moved more towards human
normal tissues and three-dimensional
tissues
a key issue has been the types of
plastics used typically the plastics
that were used initially were extremely
absorbent to the chemical so it was very
hard
to detect materials at low doses
the fluid compartments couldn't be
isolated and
really hasn't been successful in terms
of linking multiple organ ships together
to get a mimic you know human body or or
more physiologically relevant system
so while there are many advantages in
terms of specific organ mechanics and
how those mechanics might impact drug uh
movement kinetics or toxicology
the overall system
needs
has some
disadvantages
so we we started with the idea that we
need to build the science first um and
and then and then worry and the biology
and we're not going to worry about
manufacturing and selling a plate until
we know that a plate is is capable of
answering some key questions
and so we really started with a larger
plate design so this footprint
this diagram represents the footprint of
the hedemont and it's about it's a
standard micro tighter plate a microcell
culture plate size
and the wells are about the size of a
six well system
and when we use this type of a system we
can connect them by using a simulated
blood flow system and what makes this
really unique is that the only places
where these different compartments
communicate with one another is
via the simulated blood and that's
because inside each organ chamber
there's a semi-permeable membrane which
is picking up and releasing the parent
compound metabolites and even small
proteins
and we can change the surface area of
this uh
semi-permeable membrane to mimic
different parts of the body in different
and different um types of blood flow
and so in this representation here we
see again the the diagrammatic
representation although it looks rigid
keep in mind that these can be moved
around and that should be clear in the
center
picture where
you can see the cups that sit inside the
plate and those cups can be moved in any
configuration that you need and the
black
supports are for using 3d tissues
and then the fluid is moved through the
system by using a micro syringe pump
which is shown on the right
and this is just an example of a 3d
human lung tissue this this human lung
tissue tissue is mucillary it's made by
epithelium
and it fits very nicely uh into these
black supports that allow us to link
those systems together
so some of the important features then
of this new design plate platform are
that we're dealing with a larger scale
it's an integrated organ platform on a
scale that allows us to use larger
volumes and larger amounts of tissue
it's capable
compatible with most commercially
available tissue models which i'll show
you in just a moment
the simulated blood flow is is unique
it's the only way the organ chambers
communicate with one another and that's
again through a semi-permeable membrane
that's only inside each organ chamber
and inside that
that simulated blood
flow system
we have
basically a saline solution with human
serum albumin
and of course that can be adjusted to
any components that you would want to
use
so each organ and tissue can be cultured
under optimal conditions because we're
not exchanging media from one
compartment to another the oh there's no
net change in fluid in fact between the
chambers there's only a change in
molecules that have an osmotic gradient
we can calculate kinetic data because of
this
and our plastics are designed and coated
so that we have very low absorption of
drugs and chemicals
we have used the model with a set like i
said earlier many different tissue types
which you're all familiar with and i'm
going to show some of those to you now
i've already mentioned mucilaire this is
the lung model uh made by epithelix
we've used um cardiomyocytes the the eye
cell system
we use primary hepatocytes in in
standard monoculture or in sandwich
culture
um
and we've used uh the
epi intestinal system that's made by
matt tech corporation and we've had
excellent luck with this for our oral
models so
these are just examples of the different
tissue types that can be used in the
platform and other examples would
include steroids
and of course any cell line that you
happen to have experience with in your
laboratory
well when we designed this we of course
wanted it to look uh at least in
in principle like the human body and
this is just to remind us that organs
are connected by the blood system
obviously
and that's why the simulated blood flow
is important but also the sequence of
connection of one organ to another is
quite important
another important
component is the idea of dilution and
when you're putting chemicals directly
on cells and primary culture it's very
difficult to account for changes in
fluid compartments in a body
but in this type of an in-vitro platform
where we're integrating different organ
systems and we're using simulated blood
flow we actually start to account for
different volume changes and those
dilution effects and this was just a
diagram to give you an idea that as a
drug is enters the intestine by by oral
intake
it's absorbed it's diluted in the
intestine but also it's absorbed in the
portal system and diluted again
in the liver
and those volumes are shown here on the
right the stomach liver uh
volumes the total volume of 5 000 and so
if you just had an arbitrary dosing
you could see that that dilution factor
is quite large and so this this ability
to model this type of dilution effect is
really quite important
this is just to show you that um the the
outside syringes can be a single syringe
doing a flow through or multiple
syringes we can change the flow rates we
can have it flow through a hundred
percent or we can have it loop back in
uh to the system
so again the hudamp system that i'm i'm
going to be showing you data for next is
it's really it's not organ on a chip
it's mesoscale it's not it's not a full
body on a chip it's an integrated organ
platform that allows us to start asking
questions about drug or chemical
movement metabolism toxicology and
kinetics
so now i'm going to move into some proof
of concept studies to show you how the
system works
and let's start
as i mentioned earlier it's important to
be able to look at different routes of
exposure derma oral and inhalation
and in the first examples i'm going to
be showing you uh some inhalation
exposures and then later on i'll show
you some uh intestinal or oral exposure
as well
so again we have the the mat tech system
for skin we have the the lung system by
mucillar and we have the intestinal
system
by matte tech corporation
and this is a side view of a two
compartment plate system and and the
left shows you the three-dimensional
tissue grown on the insert
material is dosed at the apical surface
it diffuses through and that allows us
to monitor the movement of parent but
also any metabolites that are formed
that material is then taken up in the
basolateral chamber by the simulated
blood flow system again across that
semipermeable membrane and it's
delivered to the next compartment in
this case the liver where again we can
measure the delivery of the parent
molecule as well as the changes in the
metabolic profiles
and all of this does a great job of
mimicking the three primary fluid
compartments and biological barriers in
the body the intracellular fluid the
intravascular fluid and the interstitial
fluid
so before we start a plate study or
before we start working we've learned
over the last five or six years that we
really need to establish an
understanding of the system every time
and that includes
the movement metabolism toxicity
of molecules and in the examples i'm
going to be showing you now we're going
to be looking at diclofenac a very
well-known drug
we're going to be using a three
compartment or three organ system and
this system is interesting it's just
dermal exposure to primary human
hepatocytes to a different type of
hepatocyte over here to look at effects
of metabolites from liver 1 on liver 2.
so we're going to define non-specific
binding in a null system or a system
with no cells or tissues we're going to
look at the
cytotoxicity range so what's the maximum
polar dose we can put on without killing
our tissues
we want to confirm that the organs that
we want to be producing metabolites can
actually produce those metabolites
we need to develop the analytical system
in this case lc msms
and then finally we dose the system the
full system all linked together
and start collecting the data
again this is a dermal exposure just
showing you again the insert and the
dose is applied to the apical side
of the skin
and this is the first step we we are
just looking at toxicity or maximum dose
and then those on the dermal side
we're using a mtt assay and this fist
percent viability you can see not much
change in viability over 48 hours
in the liver we're using the primary
hepatocytes and here we see pretty
significant toxicity as the doses go up
uh expressed both in micromolar uh and
in the mass applied
and then at the bottom this shows the
development of the analytical process
and a nice
peak for diclofenac
now diclofenac
has as you
probably well know has several
metabolites the parent compound is shown
at the top left
that is hydroxylated the 4-hydroxy so we
get a hydroxylated diclofenac and it can
also be glucuronidated
so we wanted to be able to know if our
system could pick up these metabolites
over time
so the red bars on the left are showing
you the formation of the 4-hydroxy
diclofenac and you can see at the three
doses we're getting a nice increase
over time 1 6 and 24 hours
of the
metabolite now it's going down at 300
because we saw remember for in the last
slide we saw toxicity
and also the same is true with the
glucuronide again we can see the
glucuronic going up on a time dependent
manner and as toxicity occurs at the
higher dose of course it goes down
we also wanted to confirm that the
material moved across the skin so we
wanted to look at dermal absorption
and so again we can see here this is
showing you just using the the dermal
cup
to look at
the movement you can see a nice increase
over time and that allows us to
calculate permeability coefficients
and this is the beginning of the
estimates of bioavailability
so now we've got most of the prista
pre-study work completed
we we understand non-specific binding we
understand what doses we could
administer to the tissues without
causing detrimental effects we
can we've confirmed the production of
the metabolites that we want to monitor
and we've developed our anal political
method
so now we want to take that three
compartment system that i showed you a
couple of slides back which is consists
of the skin and the liver one and liver
two and we want to look at the
developing the kinetic curves that we
need to look at any type of ademi data
so this is diaclofanac dosed at 15
micrograms of mass on the apical surface
of the skin
and this is time on the y on the x-axis
and the amount of diclofenac recovered
on the y-axis and you can see
uh this is a two-dose exposure so we
dose at time zero we collect samples and
you see it nicely plateau right around
24 hours and at 24 hours it receives a
second dose again we get a rise much
like you would in vivo just as you would
expect
if we look at the other compartments now
the light yellow line uh represents the
simulated blood and you can see the
material went up quite rapidly in the
blood as you would expect in vivo as
well
and there is a slight delay as the
material moves across and into the
the
first liver which is in black and that's
lower has a lower amount of recovered
material than the red because we're
looking at parent compound and in the
black or the first liver we have much
higher rates of metabolism remember
these are the human primary hepatocytes
and the other cells are a cell line
and you can see
that that is reflective
in the material being delivered
and here we have a different dose so the
last the first dose i showed you right
here was at 15 and you can see it
plateaus around eight we increase the
dose to 30 and you can see now we've
really gone up again we're about 16 so
we're getting a nice dose response here
uh that's proportional to the dose given
um the same is true in the different
organ compartments um and we're also
seeing a nice time dependent increase in
the in the first liver compartment of
the glucuronide metabolite
again these kinetic curves are all being
generated in this plate system and all
of these data can be modeled
we look at delivery of metabolites to
the second liver compartment you can see
that the metabolites are or diclofenac
itself are causing a reduction
in total glutathione so that tells us
it's getting there we've measured it
there but it's also having a biochemical
effect
so now let's look at some other
compounds we looked at diclofenac now
i'd like to show you um
how we're moving towards trying to
estimate some of these pharmacokinetic
or add me parameters
so we're going to look at acetaminophen
and cyclohexamine we don't have time to
look at [ __ ] here today
but let's start with those
so here we have a three organ system
this time we're looking at oral
absorption so we're using the 3d human
intestine model
human hepatocytes and human
kidney cells
and we're looking for ways to calculate
auc c max and time to max
again we're looking at acetaminophen
which has low toxicity relative to
cyclohexamide an antifungal protein
synthesis inhibitor which has much
higher toxicity
now this graph on uh is it has a lot of
information but let's just start on the
left the bar graph on the left is just
telling us that the intestinal tissue is
healthy
um this is um over several different
exposures of acetaminophen and you can
see that the viability remains quite
high and the one that's quite low was
the positive control which is triton x
in the middle we have the kinetic data
the upper graph shows the absorption
across that intestinal barrier
and the elimination
the lower graph is a blow up of the
other organ compartments which are liver
kidney and the simulated blood in this
case we enabled it profusate
again we see these nice lags this is a
single dose the first example was a
double dose this is a single dose
at time zero
and then lastly we looked at some
cytotoxicity at the end of the
experiment now this is ldh leakage on
the basal lateral surface of the
intestinal chamber this is the apical
surface and these this is normal because
these cells
will slough off
you can see this is a model of that 3d
intestinal chamber these cells will
actually slough off from the crypt just
as they do in vivo so that increases the
ldh from the apical wash we're focusing
on the basolateral side again really low
toxicity
below two twofold changes in ldh
out out on the kidney side
uh in the liver there's there's almost
no toxicity on the kidney side we see a
little bit more and acetaminophen does
have a higher toxicity
in the kidney
we also looked at genes associated with
toxicity and this is just a table of
those to give me an example we looked at
bax bcl2 nerf glutathione pathways
some cytokines for inflammation and and
then some key
sip enzymes
and this uh table at the top shows you
the gene changes so this was done with
rt pcr uh the organs are on the left the
genes across the top and anything in
green is more than a two-fold induction
and for the acetaminophen the intestine
the liver and the kidney
compartments not much happening as you'd
expect for a molecule that's very safe
for cyclohexamite
we see the a little more activity again
not much activity uh in the intestinal
tissues it's pretty
robust
but in the center we see a nice increase
across the intestinal model but a delay
in the elimination phase
and this is
we see this with changes in log p as
well as molecular size
and then down the bottom again we see
nice uptake
in the other organs
there is more toxicity
at time points here in the intestine you
can see that all the multiple time
points now are nearly at five again the
two big bars of the apical side in the
liver we see significant toxicity and
just a little bit at the last time point
in the kidney again this is from two to
uh 48 hours
of measurements
so again we're we're looking at this uh
this model and trying to predict the c
max and the time to c max and actually
these values are really quite similar to
what we see uh in vivo and that was true
uh when we did the um uh in
acetaminophen as well that time to see
the c-max and the c-max values
themselves
so it's very encouraging uh data for us
as we as we move forward with these
models and for cyclohexamine now we're
looking at the gene expression profiles
again anything in green is two or
greater in terms of its full chain we
see a lot more green meaning a lot more
genes are impacted across multiple
organs and again the bars reflect that
um here at the bottom and the dashed
line just represents that two-fold uh
threshold that that um that i've been
talking about
and lastly i just want to introduce um
we we have partnered with vitra cell to
develop a an in vitro way to expose the
plate the the 3d lung tissue on the
plate to aerosols and vapors and this is
just an example of what that of what
that system looks like
so in summary then i've shown you data a
lot of data actually um on the on on the
hudam platform which is a a
microphysiology system that is based on
measles scale formats
which enables multiple tissue and liquid
sampling
capabilities
we're showing you that it's possible to
generate very nice kinetic data
that means that you can model the system
um multiple organ systems can be
monitored different different groups can
be put together you know i showed you
primarily you know a lung a skin to
liver a lung to a test in the liver but
we can also do lung and we're also now
experimenting with blood brain barrier
and neuro uh brain deliveries
uh the test the testing paradigm allows
faster development uh we think uh we
believe it will it will increase the
the way it'll improve the way we design
and approve drugs
um and we're very excited about working
with various companies around the world
right now
even developing this and validating the
system
even more and the current iteration of
the plate it looks like this
again
these cups can be moved around um if
it's very flexible to run two
compartments three compartments four or
five compartments
um this is just a a picture again
uh to give you a little better a view of
what it looks like
and with that i will uh close and thank
you for attending
the the webinar series today
and i really look forward to your
questions
and to answering them
via email thank you